[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ten games ten drawers
as the two best chess players in the
world for another high-level exciting
battle to keep their fans wondering who
will finally land a knockout punch with
only two games left one mistake to
jeopardize the entire match it's Bobby
versus Magnus game 11 starts right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our World
Championship coverage of Carl's sanic
arowana we are in game 11 out of 12 and
we see here the wounded world champion
on his face not on the board so far both
players uh nicked as we see the reigning
king magnus carlsen first of Fabiano
carolina the first american challenger
for the undisputed crown since bobby
fischer and he hails from st. Louis
where we are currently bringing you our
coverage of the World Championship and
we're in round 11
yes any predictions well I'm predicting
a more great chance what can I say
during the free day yesterday I got a
chance to revisit game 10 and played
over some of the variations and it was
only in that free day that I got this
chance to really appreciate how well and
how accurate both players were in game
10 new worlds record 10 games 10 draws
to start a world championship match
we've got two games left Jennifer it's
been it's just it's just been a saga
fest they're just fighting themselves to
a standstill it's really hard to say it
any other way
just incredible incredible chassis eyes
to me it really feels like they're
hitting the limits of the human brain
without assistance and that's why that's
why this match is so historic to me in
addition to seeing I'm Bobby take his
shot at the crown but let's take a look
at the remaining schedule yes and that
just two games left to go including
today's fight where Magnus will get a
crack with the white pieces exactly for
c-44 we're gonna find out very soon
we're gonna be above meanwhile Fabiano
arrest day on Sunday tomorrow and then a
championship Monday we think
championship Monday with foggy with the
white pieces if needed tie breaks on
November 28th that's Wednesday that will
be rapid and blitz and we take a look at
our format the classical games which we
have two more we have a luxurious
three-part time control no drawl offers
before Black's 30th and a prized fan of
over a million euros exactly as well as
all the fame and fortune that comes with
being the world chess champion the most
valuable thing of all know now and right
now we are still waiting a champion in
London but we do have a new women's
world champion just crowned in
containment seas congratulations to
Gendron of China and Maryse has the
details
yes well well the whole world waits to
see who wins between Fabiano and Magnus
the women have decided their contest in
a thrilling affair and a tie break and
the winner is the reigning world
champion and still women's world
champion Joe engine of China
congratulations to her she wins $60,000
for winning this event that she did need
to go pass rapid to ten plus ten and it
was there that she was able to overcome
her opponent in two with two victories
to take the title this is her second
title this year as she won this
64-player knockout tournament and also a
match against her country woman Tang
Xiang Yi in May so kudos to her she must
be very relieved as all of China China
will be hailing her on her epic return
and now this round as we look at the
history of world chess championship
classical matches only twice as the
loser of the penultimate game bounced
back to win the next one and that was
from sec 1978 car for playing courts no
in Baguio in 1987 just borrow vs. car
pub in Seville trying to try to win
after losing is not easy and it's only
happened twice so that really underlines
the importance of today's contest well
game eleven will indeed be epic we will
be following it all closely as the game
is underway Thank You Maurice and our
congratulations as well to Joo Engine
for a terrific victory Wow the ladies
really
did regale us great day we have a Petrov
on our board the players have really
zoomed right into it yeah III suggested
English okay so in the previous time
that Magnus was white in this world
championship match he played the petrov
he played the really lame night d3 I've
never seen you hate a move so much yeah
don't do that
you know like South immoral ate our
pieces 93 was played but in a return to
the Sinquefield Cup 2018 between these
two players Magnus and Fabiano castles
I believe we have seen a couple of moves
since this time just a second I
apologize I'm just gonna have to read
about this opening for Team Bobby for
commentators I'm a little bit as well
because I think we do have castling in
the opposite sides already which is
terrific Magnus is known to play this
line and of course he needs to make sure
to use bolstered so yes I I felt like
Maggie got so much more out of c4 than
he did out of any other move so I was
kind of most scared of that myself the
English will ya essentially in the
Grandmaster chess when you're when your
opponent has why you're only afraid of
really two moves
efore and d4 if you've got a terrific
defense for efore it's fantastic it's
really really really great then you only
really worried about d4 and vice versa
we know that Fabiano plays the Russian
defense or the petrov really really well
and when Magnus essayed the Petrov for
the first time he nearly lost a game
let's be frank
today he's basically saying I'm putting
my world
ship title on the fact that I'll be able
to do something good with the white
pieces against your vaunted Petrov let's
see what he's prepared so far it's all
very very standard as you say white has
castled on opposite sides he's king on
the Queen side blacks King on the Kings
side normally speaking white is trying
to get an offense going on the Kings
side with his pawns whereas black tries
to do the same thing with his pawns on
the Queen side Bishop d3 I mean not a
hundred percent sure this is the exact
position but I do remember in the sink
fill Cup Magnus s8 an early Bishop to c4
yeah which actually boomerang against
him and that game was a draw he didn't
go for that instead he put his Bishop on
d3 protecting against any potential of
94 and again why does usually thinking
in terms of how can I expand on the
Kings side and get my pawns funny that
this line became popular because I
remember like I started playing this
line at some point you think it's white
yeah I just wanted something a little
bit more like slash-and-burn but I I
never could have dreamed that it would
become the most popular line for the
elite grandmasters because it looks a
little bit like thin right yeah you know
you get this attack that's great if you
were you know not at the 2800 level but
I figured at that level like come on
this is really enough to justify having
the double pawns and then right and
considering like the very very solid
nature of blacks position sure but
apparently the answer is yes because
it's become so popular well you want an
imbalance and you want to get yourself
into a situation where you know you've
got a very clear idea you want to attack
your opponent's king and if you're
willing to risk having the you know that
happened to you black wants to attack
his opponent's king then guess what
you found you know a perfect opening for
both yourselves this line of the petrov
know from blacks point of view he's got
to get some activity going
see five this move strikes me as a very
decent move or if step of you will in
the right direction first of all your
black limits any opportunities that
white may have of redeploying his knight
on f3 to d4 to f5 secondly by putting up
this pawn on c5 he's kind of creating an
opportunity for a wedgie kind of attack
with b5 before like yeah and a hook
there on the c3 square so then after
this move I think are we up to date with
c5 the last move Maurice that's the last
move I have okay now I might have to beg
to differ with you guys about this
opening being happy with the opening
first of all Magna is prepared it deeply
exactly there's no question magnus
prepared is not about how well Fabiano
has played this in history magnus has
prepared this extremely deeply he knew
he was gonna see a petrov at some point
now he's seen it twice and there's no
question that his handlers have studied
everything they need to study as deeply
as possible now second note Fabiano did
not replay the game that they played in
st. Louis here where we stand
earlier this year he actually ducked the
line because after Bishop III he castled
in this position and put in he castled
in this game but in this one back in a
safer couple a knight c6 so a completely
different treatment of this opening he
played a nice e6 the game went Bishop c4
it is the famous Church game as we call
it Bishop c4 castles and then Queen d2
Bishop f5 castles Queen side Queen d7 he
seemed to have gotten what looked like a
decent position for him always
sooner or later being able to play a
move like d5 or competing with this
Bishop we weren't sure what it was doing
there but after a couple of moves we
suddenly saw this position arise and
Bishop g4 9 h2 Bishop takes Queen takes
and it again looked like black should be
okay no weaknesses but we saw the
expansion on this side
Bishop c1 that was an excellent move
queen c6 and then f4 and all of a sudden
this stuff started hitting the fan as we
saw this move gee
for land and slowly but surely probably
started getting pushed off the board and
should have lost that game if Magnus had
found the right moves so I'm a bit more
concerned than you guys are about the
condition for white for black let's just
be real
we're talk about the world champion here
and this is his last white he's not
going into the guy's best defense with
just just so oh let me give you an easy
drawer something he's got something
deeply prepared and that's why Fabi
ducked in my opinion and prepared
something totally different with this
idea of c5 this is a line that has been
seen before quite a few times in fact
there's no consensus as how I should
play why it has multiple moves to come
out of this position but here we see
Magnus thinking for the first time in
the game giving an extended think has he
may have prepared that other line we
looked at might have gone in depth there
looked at some other things but he
couldn't know that this is exactly what
Fabiano had prepared so back for the
Fabi fans they might be happy that Fabi
has prepared a new wrinkle something
different something to throw Magnus off
and not be deep in the wells of his
preparation it's funny that game that
you showed from the Sinquefield Cup
reminds me of like Magnus at top form
until he didn't win it but my god that
game was just watching that game I was
blown away I thought that was vintage
magnets kind of like Game one of this
match where it's just you it's kind of
unbelievable how well he plays did you
just have a regular position and the guy
seems to be making good moves and all of
a sudden it's dead right I love that
game yeah the beauty of this conception
of like literally every move being a
link in this perfect chain and then it
was just so like in both instances the
first game of this match and in the same
fill Cup he makes this beautiful
beautiful portrait and then he forgets
to finish it with by signing his name of
the flourish and two draws I mean as a
huge Fabi fan but as a lover of chess
it's almost painful to watch especially
Andy being a child yes in that watching
those games being spoiled in the fashion
they were now having said that Maurice
here said that the there was this
different approach instead of knight c6
and
85s played in the 2018 Sinquefield cup
here in st. Louis we've seen an early
night b8 to d7 to f6 what's the
theoretical what's the theory has
anybody made a novelty according to our
database not yet and in fact this will
c5 is a bit of an unusual move in the
database and I'm looking at the play I'm
looking at when it was first played
played by Leger a player not high ranked
on a listener and somebody we all know
right
but then picked up by one Alexander
castaigne who as we knows former women's
world champion from Russia
now she played this line four times but
not with great success this move c5 and
it was also picked up at some point in
2016 by one pen Tala Hari Krishna
against Carr yakin and in that game
black lost and I'm looking at these the
statistics at the higher levels and the
lower levels black doing fine but when
you look at the top level play even Giri
was on the side with the on the white
side against multi level when you start
looking at the higher level play Black
has not fared that well in this line but
the good news is there's no real
consensus I'm seeing six different moves
here white has tried rookie 1 h 3 C 4 H
for a couple of times rookie one is the
most popular with seven most ninety-five
ones King B 1 is a multiplicity of ideas
here that white has attempted rook H e1
being the most standard one looks like a
natural developing move but no big
agreement so if Magnus has not prepared
this which it looks like he hasn't I
mean looking back at the live board
Magnus is still thinking no I'm here ok
Jim play the main move rook H e1 and
this would be six coming back very
quickly so we are definitely in fabi's
preparation how deep into Magnus's
preparation with great clarity is he
that is the question as obviously Bobby
this information advantage goes to Fabi
this time because Magnus did not know he
was going to play this line still it's
been good
why if I can make a shout-out to onigiri
one of our grand chests or players of
the past
how did on each approach the position
Maurice did was he one of the players
who played rook on H 1 e 1 I have a very
very high respect for honest approach
guess who made the first move today of
Carlsen the Carolina it looks like
that's Sergey Karjakin
did make the first move bagi I guess
that's why he play 24 right wow what a
throwback I gotta say for the
superstitious among us you you can't
help but feel like that advantage Maggie
yeah no throwing back to the World
Championship from two years ago
of course luckily I don't I'm not I
don't believe in superstition no not
unless they favor me yeah well okay so
we have a bias there
here's I'd rook on h1 to e1 Bishop e6
and back to you Maurice
how did oddish approach the position was
he one of the rook h 1 e 1 enthusiasts
he was and this is the line okay so for
cage Brooke H e1 Bishop e6 he played
Bishop g5 against Poncelet this was in
the World Cup by the way 2017 and second
round so very important event Queen a5
played a3 rook fe8 trade on f6 followed
by Knight g5 a quick trade on g5 and
they got this position and you look at
it it looks very sterile all right this
doesn't look like that much happening in
the position it did continue though for
another 30 almost 30 moves with this
move
g4 looking to get his hook on that side
Queen d8 stopping the move Bishop to e2
and Queen g5 Trading of Queens and this
did not produce an advantage for for
white so this position has been seen on
each play this way not much maybe this
is how far B plans to play
as well he's certainly seen the game
there's no question about that right
what is he prepared or I should say what
is Magnus counter prepared having seen a
position like this or did he look at it
deeply that's what we're gonna find out
soon it's been a while
speaking of a Sergey Kuryakin it's been
a little while but I remember reading in
a new in chest that he actually said he
wanted Bobby to win and the reason was
not because he's a great friend of
Bobby's but he wants to see Magnus play
the candidates join join your colleagues
you might be the best player but does
that make you that makes you a favorite
in technically but it doesn't make you
the favorite against the field and
that's what really blew me away about
you and June congratulations again
defending her title I mean boy defending
her title among sixty-three hopefuls
including ten over ten players who were
than 100 rating points from her I know
it's so hard it's funny because she
technically she was the favorite but of
course also a huge underdog versus the
field
exactly oh no no no I think one of the
biggest challenge if not the biggest
challenge in the world of chess today is
actually qualifying from the candidates
to become the Challenger it is just so
hard a field of eight elite players and
there can only be one winner so I think
whoever wins that event is absolutely
beating the odds
just as chu and June did in her World
Championships she did get some favorable
pairings that that said because she was
the number one seed so not believing her
accomplishment in any way but it is nice
to be the number one seed she got paired
down heavily in the first few rounds and
she's the only player in the field well
maybe no I'm wrong about that I think
humpin can arrow was another one who
broke 2600 who has actually surpassed
that 2600 marker her high being some
like 2604 I think it is so she was
better than everybody else I mean that
is the case but again as you guys said
to prove it to keep your nerves to lose
in them in the match against Katarina
like no to lose that
- and they come back and win with black
and game for a must win win must win
game but to take it to a tie-break and
then handler business in the tiebreak
and it was really more of a collapse on
lag nose part in the tiebreak as well as
she could have kept the the ball rolling
but just made two really key mistakes
but when it gets to that point the
champions rise and show their toughness
their determination their guts their
fortitude and all-important their steely
nerves and she was able to show that and
that is why she's still the champion
right Maurice a quick question for you
about this exact game position after the
move rook on h1 to e one as we've seen
we've seen this response bishop on g5 to
e6
fair enough developing a piece we're all
about development we love development
attacking upon on a - one of the things
one of the drawbacks I looking at
White's position is this knight on f3 as
good as it is it's a it's on its
starting blocks and it's not moving it's
not moving to d4 because of that moves
c5 it's not moving to e5 due to the pawn
on d6 but I start to be attracted to the
move Knight g5 attacking the bishop on
the one hand if you play like Bobby
Fischer and capture this pawn on a2
after the move b2 b3 you might have your
regrets
like Bobby did that the bishop is going
to get trapped now that's not the end of
the world and end of the variation
because there's still a 5 to consider
and the potential for peace track rifice
the other idea of Bishop defy funnily
enough you can get your Bishop trapped
another way by something of this nature
where you may regret that you have been
up the Kings side after f3 so I'm just
thinking yeah has Knight g5 been si it
has not and if you like continue with
your line there which Bishop takes a to
Bishop takes a greedy greedy greedy yes
let's go and then b3 yes well take a
look that Bishop on e7 is laying in wait
if you can get to a3 its mate so we just
need to clear the pawns out of the way
so start with c4 with tempo
I see and now you capture back with the
bishop obviously and now d5 with tempo
and suddenly Bishop 83 mate is being
threatened with that on the board yeah
and the actual maid oh I see
checkmate happen in the gate and king b2
so that's just one way eight five was
also possible according to the engines
but this way it looks pretty compelling
that that move Bishop takes a two is
just fine and you'll be scrambling to
try to prove why you gave this pawn back
well then that pictures asking the
Queen's were already off the board right
yeah and just trying I mean it does look
I mean it is greedy to grab this pawn on
a to rescue me my own bishop you play
yeah I've just I've been kind of
experimenting I understand that b3 does
potentially running with before I was
thinking about something wild what about
b5 I mean yeah doesn't this just change
the Nate you'd have to really be
analyzing this position to not to want
to enter here if you were white yeah
it's a core of yourself exactly you see
one thing that apparently Sergei
Kuryakin has been doing some official
commentary he says he's actually
critiquing Magnus's opening choices he
says playing the Sicilian with black and
then playing something boring with white
it's not very connected but this
position that you're looking at right
now it doesn't look good why no no no no
I I'm really picking up the gauntlet
with the move Knight g5 no question
about it but what does he mean when he's
saying that cuz these lines looking
really exciting I guess some of the time
these lines fizzle out pretty quickly
what it takes on c3 like yes
occasionally you get these great attacks
yeah but sometimes you get a little bit
of sizzle and physical oh you see
referring to this game if I may jump in
I don't think he's referring to this ya
know I think he is I think he is he's
saying that this is boring well ya know
maybe maybe it was earlier but you just
saw the very early mark yeah maybe are
you I mean you know but in general I
think I think in Jim
he's right though isn't it yeah right in
general White has been really tepid but
part of that has been black controlling
the way the games have gone sure right
so white white has tried some
interesting lines this D and D for but
Fabia keeps coming up with novelty after
novelty in Magnus keeps going I'm not
going into that stuff and backing away
from them so Magnus has been very solid
with the white pieces Plan C for a
couple of times playing D for a couple
of times as well and now he's over to e4
for his second time right but it's true
people criticize this opening for that
which does look seem a little strange
especially janitors watching because
it's like what do you want Maggie is
castling queenside isn't that exciting
right so kind of break down why people
sometimes criticize and for instance
even Gary one time criticized it was not
playing the white side of this saying
that this is insipid are they just
saying it's not high-quality enough to
get an edge oh I don't know how to
answer that because it's one of the
major lines played by all the elite
players so if you want to say it's an
insipid line well you're basically
insulting all of the elite players who
played this including by the way
Sergey Carrie rockin there is a very
funny thing was I remember Boris Gelfand
Boris playing the black side of the
night off and just incredibly
double-edged super short games and then
whenever he was white he was playing d4
c4 g3 Bishop g2 Knight f3 really really
tepid Catalans you know just really easy
nothing going on with white but when he
was black man he's just throwing caution
tornado chess the black so maybe that's
maybe that's what's that with the taker
but that has a lot to do not with the
opening but with Bobby's joys he's
playing the petrov so I don't see that
as being Maggie at fault but so you
disagree you know you don't think that
this you think that this game really
does have potential
a slugfest just like the Thanksgiving
game no question about it and if you're
playing against the petrol how do you
get you know a wide open a game do you
get it by playing d4 and Bishop d3 and
going into the main variations with c4 I
don't know how you get anything other
than a balanced game here at least with
the with the players canceling on
opposite sides I think you have a good
chance of getting something very sharp
now by the way that Gary comment was way
later in the game that was like a Magnus
game where he Carl played this with the
white side and just didn't get anything
in the lesser side yes and we go to that
cardiac and Harry cristiano game this is
three games that we've seen at the high
level in this line coming out of our
database obviously there's games that
get played that they don't make the
database but the ones that have we have
three high level games and one was the
Giri month of that game we talked about
one was Marika versus Castilla in this
position and now also the game that
we're gonna look at now car yeah kyun
versus higher Krishna patella Hydra
Krishna was 20 top 2700 player and the
move beat Bishop g5 was essayed in all
three of those games and after this move
Hari Krishna played the move eight-six
against car yakun that's just like a red
flag to a bull because Kuryakin
instantly captured on eight-six
I don't know how instant it was but it
happened on the next move he just ripped
off this pawn on eight-six saying go
ahead take my piece if you will and
obviously if you capture right now then
Queen takes on eight-six and this attack
is playing itself Knight g5 rookie six
sacrifices your king is gonna get
shredded in this position after Bishop
uses he played the move c4 looking to
try to distract this bishop and he said
go ahead take it if you want to Bishop
takes e7 ker-splat ripping open this
King side and after C takes on d3 Queen
g5 and is all bleeding in this position
as White's attack crashed through very
easily after
move Queen eighty-six Queen g5 check we
saw this trade and when it was all said
and done it was too much material for
white rook takes the six King f8 and h4
and and then King takes on c2 he had a
rook and six pawns for the bishop at
night I think that's a little too much
to be trying to fighting it and he went
on to win this game easily now this game
has been looked at very deeply so you
say why is Fabi going into this line
Bishop g5 looks pretty dangerous well we
saw the month to live game but also
there's some deep analysis and an
annotation in this position from the
game the move d5 is principled here in
this position d5 going right ahead and
the argument that Queen f4 looks
dangerous like you're putting heavy
pressure but to put the Queen on h4 then
there's gonna be mating ideas you played
six there's still the sacrificial
possibilities but Queen b6 is apparently
the way to sidestep this line and now if
Queen h4 this h6 excuse me Queen h4 h6
Bishop takes h6g takes h6 Queen takes in
this find the move Knight to e4 when I
must be move down to move I'm sorry
Queen takes 86 I got a whole bunch of
analysis going on here in this moment
and it looks like rook e8 rook e8
forgive me guys because the analysis
goes so deep in this position but rook
this rook to e8 keeping the possibility
of playing 94 and blocking this mating
idea there goes my screen yeah but this
is the very very sharp line being given
as the analysis that white will have to
face if he plays Bishop g5 the d5 coming
now I'm trying to get back to this game
instead he's played an alternate move
and it looks like we've gone into
nothing sharp at all I mean talk about
snoozefest
he did play we have we have I have moves
and the move I have is Bishop e6 King be
one Queen a5 see for Queen d2 Bishop
takes d2 is this enough this reminds me
then of how
in the game in the sink poke up Maggie
also happen early Queen trade and at
first we thought it was a lot he got the
game by the way to correct myself I was
I was reviewing that game that for some
reason I had remembered the Maggie
Nakamura game for the very first
Sinquefield Cup as a pet cop it was
actually a Berlin in the line where you
avoid the cream treats right rookie won
yeah Berlin right it feels like it could
have come from a Petrov but that's
actually a Berlin move order yeah
exactly and that was the one that Caspar
I was like yeah maybe this isn't enough
although it's would that too became like
very popular for a little while and I
think people have kind of abandoned it
now because it wasn't giving much yeah
well it's like the Berlin endgame
started scaring people too as they
realize well blacks not without
resources so they started playing this
very tepid line with rookie one just as
you were mentioning and although as
you're right it was the very first Cinco
2013 that was one you annotated for the
exact created exactly and the point
there was though that in 2013 people
forget while Magnus won the tournament
it was actually Nakamura with the
terrific start believe he actually
scored two and a half out of three and
he needed a draw or a win against Magnus
and he wins the tournament that's why he
also played it very conservatively that
rookie one variation but okay now we
have so what's going on here Maurice
just a second correct the variation I
just gave the move indeed is Knight to
e4 in this position being suggested
route PA 94 is in fact the right move
here and the sacrifice begins rook takes
on e4 takes on e4 back let me get that
there Bishop takes e4 looks like a
withering attack but now the long-term
point of Queen b6 reveals itself and
suddenly Bishop f5 shows up counter
defending this position
hitting the queen hitting the bishop you
can get your piece it Sue's me you can
get your piece with Queen b6 a b6 Bishop
f5 rook a 2 and we get this position
where the assessment is unclear by the
annotators now this is sharp stuff
this is not what Magnus wants to do but
it looks more interesting than what they
have now which looks very much like it
can lead towards a draw and Magnus was
asked the players in fact we're asked
well how would you solve the problem of
a draw where maybe we should try what
they're gonna do in Norway chess in
altar box Norway later in next year when
they play this tournament the point
being that if there's a draw you play an
Armageddon game immediately after this
is what the players have to say no we're
trying to use some new groups next year
for example go to Amara you think
[Music]
[Music]
there goes Bobby with with the logic
yeah I missed it a little bit it was
like 16 I heard that Maggie wants Magnus
part me once 16 to 18 games a longer
match Bobby just said he absolutely
doesn't wanna play Armageddon although
it's kind of interesting I wonder if I
beat probably doesn't look like Bobby
actually addressed the longer match
because I think maybe he would like that
I mean why not that way you get to play
more of these classical games and it
does kind of feel like every time with
white he's getting more and more I don't
get it I don't think that Magnus is
trying to draw this position and trying
to draw out the match maybe taking a
little bit fewer risks but he must be
terrified of Bobby's white preparation
so I kept imagining thrilled about the
prospect that going into the last round
needing a draw to get to the tiebreak
yeah it's well I the match is very
confounding and what are the players
thinking I just know that after these 10
consecutive draws the players are really
getting more and more risk-averse
because they just can't afford to lose I
mean they're the match is over suddenly
you know anybody loses today's game is a
huge dog that's it the match is over so
if I'm white am I happy about the move
c3 c4 forcing an ending where you know
like a little bit better tiny I take no
risk I mean it's not heroic we want to
see the world champion defending his
title
you know grandly and so on I mean if
these remaining two games are both drawn
we're gonna Magnus is going to be
criticized as a player who's played
twenty four World Championship match
games won one and lost one yeah
congratulations on your critics but I
won the match both matches if the title
is in his pocket he'll take the
criticism sure that that is true though
I mean we're gonna say like I see why is
you you played 24 games and only won
once
yeah and you lost once you broke even in
two matches and only the tiebreaker
rules are helping you because you're
such a fantastic rapid and Bliss player
and you'll say rules are rules
yep rules you gave it to me and that's
what I'm gonna take now take advantage
of it because that's my skill set and
don't you know I'm playing against
really good players yeah well so it's
not like I just can't beat them I'm
trying but it's not so easy to beat them
so Bobby has shown himself to be equal
to Magnus and classical chess that we've
seen I mean you know their ratings are
deadlocked
16 18 24 games I mean I don't see the
difference so far see it's just part of
his legacy this ruthless practicality
that the more games that he plays the
more moves that he played is the better
chance he has to win that's his
philosophy if I get the time I get my 16
game match after all right
of course Magna is very well known for
being the guy whose move quality does
not reduce as much as it most players do
in wrap it right there were very high
average move quality he's
extraordinarily consistent yeah so that
you know garry kasparov who by the way
it's gonna be coming on the show Gary's
joining Gary always likes to talk in my
predecessors and in interviews about
what each player represents in terms of
the history of the world and the history
of chess and for Magnus's Ruth or at
ruthless practicality
I find it uh I find it quite interesting
and perhaps the legacy is that he wins
with the least amount of risk right as
you say which is fine right which is a
different philosophy yes I'm sorry that
sounds very much like petrosian's
already has that one in his pocket is
now trying to steal petrosian's fire
I take no chances at all and just win
with least amount of risk that's even
true a nice description of him not at
least amount of risk but like very
mathematical interpretation like looking
at the rules and seeing what
mathematically if I ran this millions of
times like a simulation I'm gonna run
this match millions of times what gives
me the best chances to win that'll be my
strategic exactly exactly and I I feel
like a you know Magnus has been known to
play a little poker and he's just
obviously an all-around brilliant guy I
kind of like that but he had not maybe
not by a game by game early Queen trade
not as thrilling to the commentators but
that approach to the game and what it
means for the history of the world I
find really interesting the history of
the world you said that these guys are
representing the culture of less risk
and you know what it's a it's a great
version it's a great story I I I'm not
one to take offence easily but if I've
already Magnus issues I would definitely
take offense at that statement like I
think that strategically speaking at the
very end of the match as the tiebreak
gets closer right if you haven't landed
a punch then you start thinking okay so
where are my advantages but only as the
tiebreak gets closer right before then
you're trying to win games and that's
much more that's an easier thing to do
than have to take a chance in a
tie-break or to try to pull off and he
has been trying so that's so I know that
I think he's been trying with both
colors he's been out prepared when he
has why he'd better change what his best
chance was with black he's had better he
may have had better chances with black
but he's been out prepared in that he
has me able to land a punch is like
trying and trying and trying he can't
land anywhere because probably keeps
coming up with opening novelties that
he's not another one
I can't go into that so the fact that he
has avoided the main preparation he's
been stung before doing it
don't forget Game three off the return
match against anon when he got hit right
out of the opening didn't even have a
chance to play moves it didn't matter
that he was the better player it's in
the matter that he dominated the match
in the end the reality is he went into a
line the opening moves and that's it bye
preparation see you later mr. world
champion he doesn't want to see that
happen again he knows what that's like
so he avoids the main moves and he tries
to outplay his opponents in these
technical positions but gary has said it
the opponents have caught up they've
caught on and caught up they're not
letting him win the way he always used
to and that is now a need for him to
switch strategies and say what do I need
to do now to start beating these guys
who used to be bread and butter in
positions that I would get this is one
of them by the way this is one of those
old-school positions where people would
say Magnus you don't have a lot here
give me give Magnus in this position in
2012 2013 2014 milk the cow baby he's
winning
why would Magnus be insulted by what I
said I was saying that his legacy isn't
impaired by potentially winning in Thai
right I would say he's practical saying
Easy's he's you know calculating out
like the way it sounds to be like
sneaking in there you know I sneak in
and just you know do do what I have to
do to win this match it doesn't doesn't
quite sound right it sounds like what it
sounds like I'm sorry
I mean I'm overstating the insulted part
but it sounds like you're saying that he
is not really trying so hard in the
classical games which he hasn't been
immensely trying I think right now he's
he's just he's just not getting done
because I was saying that it I don't
think it Mars his legacy as a world
champion which is something you know
that that is representing all of history
yeah but the reason but the reason why
this time this ruthless practicality as
opposed to the great fighter that he is
that's where I'm wondering in how he'd
feel about it because because calling
him practical is you know it's like a
little bit of a you know you don't
really want to fight when you get going
gets going do you you
- just go it's a it's a safe he's good
at math and you know in good at rules
yeah which is something that a lot of
chess players aren't good at like if you
want to have a chess player troubleshoot
a tournament or tell you how to
structure a tournament usually don't
want to ask them because sometimes their
ideas are just self bias towards I
really feel like magnets it's like an
exception in that like any rules you
give him he's gonna look for the way to
maximize it right yeah I think that
you're both right actually I think that
he is a great fighter and he does
understand the rules and the wrists and
he properly judges when he should go
all-out or when he should just play for
a tight break really really backfire
here yeah it's cuz he is white in the
last game is Fabi is Fabian you know
when it was against Kuryakyn it was very
different because we could take the
opening and everything and this goes
back to Magnus is ruthless practicality
that he chose to be black in the last
round a mathematical factor that he
thought was more relevant that there was
a chance to get match would end in 11
games and then why not have the extra
white piece I said you know could end up
biting him instead he's gonna be against
Carolina and not only Carolina but teen
Carolina okay turned out to be
phenomenal no what about this position
yes what do you think all all a side of
previous magnets former Magnus what
about you you're playing against another
player in the world yeah how do you feel
about your own chances of white I prefer
what it's that simple
but are you disappointed with the okay
opening outcome or do you think it's
about par for the course better but how
much yeah you know the weird thing did
Jen this has been a very strange match
for me to understand I still don't think
I fully get it I haven't completely
processed because in all of the World
Championship matches that I've ever
studied white was the dictator having
white was a very very very big edge and
this is one of those strange strange
matches were neither player or it was
doing anything with the white pieces so
right now in considering
what the match has been like I'd have to
say this is better than par for the
course for white I mean it's a matter
compared to this value in this match
yeah because what has been getting
nothing to disadvantage okay I've been
going from disadvantage both whites not
both wise obviously Fabi has gotten
advantages with white in both his last
two whites that's right as the English
but I'm saying Magnus but for Magnus
Magnus when he played the petrov got a
disadvantage got a dissonant when when
Fabiano play the petrov again at least
walk in the first game right well I
thought some people were saying that he
was he was surprised well yeah well yeah
wait a minute just a sec hold on time
right time to type out Magnus the first
time you was wide got into a rook and
pawn endgame upon down okay is it a
disadvantage with the white pieces
almost right out of from their opening
wasn't that the famous I'm gonna grovel
for a draw comment from no that was that
was another we don't know what that
means before a game the Queens gambit
declined when you played Bishop e2
against rook d8 is when he said exactly
and he got any and he got worse now
having said that let's talk about this
game in particular first of all there's
a backward pawn on the d6 square right
so that's something I might have to be
able to nibble on attacking this
backward pawn so you're likely to
liquidate with d6 d5 and I'm gonna take
and then I'm gonna have to see
Foursquare to work with I can get to my
Knight to e5 and maybe not my Knight to
c4 secondly I don't see any real
opportunities of a 6 and b5
coming on the Queen side maybe like the
sync Phil 2018 game I'll be able to do
something on the on the King side myself
with ideas like Knight h4 to f5 maybe I
can pop over here
or I can play for h3 and G for any King
side attack based upon getting
pawn to f4 and so on so I'm saying that
from whites point of view I find it
easier to play white eye I see more
opportunity in the position for white
than I do black I'm gonna I'm gonna be
happy with that outcome I mean it's it's
small I'm not rocking the world this
isn't moving the hearts and minds of the
American public I completely misjudged
that single cup game because at a
certain moment I thought hey this is
okay Fabiana is doing fine and I didn't
think the end game was really dangerous
for him and then suddenly it was like my
jaw you know fell to the table and I
went oh my god yeah you didn't play any
bad moves but suddenly his game was
really on the ropes and Murray's already
showed us that game here in the
broadcast but I just think that if you
now that you know what you know of
course you'd say that that edge was
bigger right yeah but the feeling that
you have now compared to the feeling
that you had when you saw that game kind
of similar precisely it is very very
very similar and again I do see h3 g4 if
black isn't careful he can he can end up
in a kind of a plan 'less middle game by
the way do we have a just trying to get
an insight into the opening anything
about the times it seems like Maggie has
on the clock is sinking into a deep
saying after the move h6p she's speaking
of 86
Harry Krishna himself has tweeted about
his game saying that he blundered with a
jinx
in the game that I lost quickly yes yes
and add a few more accurate moves and he
would have drown okay so he trying to
defend everyone's looking at that game
back I'm just the games just was in the
opening yeah
eight-six was a was a mistake holler
yeah but but with a few more accurate
moves like well we're talking about it
was a foot maybe you met draw it draw
yes okay okay so how goes here burries
yeah what do you think
why is Magnus going into such a deep
thing when he has some very simple
choices everything's right h4 by the way
from night h4 to h2 h3 he did go why is
he going into a deep lane and and was
that a good good choice Murray's a very
interesting moment in the game this move
Knight h4 not simple at all it's
initiates some interesting tactics to
look at for example right now the move
Knight h4 on the board he had to
calculate this move Knight to g4
attacking both attacking the F pawn each
part a little bit delicate but also the
knight on h4 so this position is did he
prepare this position or is he confident
that he's just fine and maybe better
here the move Knight h4 can be met I
mean the move Knight g4 can be met by
Knight to g6 attacking the bishop
attacking the rook and the bishop you
capture here then rook takes on e6 now
hitting the Jeep on and hitting the
bishop on e7 so he must have looked at
this line very carefully and decided
that this was going to be okay for him
they just saying triple zeros here just
fine for black so because of Knight
takes F to a very sharp Knight takes F
to hitting both of these guys of course
rook to e1 being given as the move
Knight takes D 3 C takes D 3 and once
again one of these pawns one of these
buttons is going to drop black and ops
for his d6 pawn going after rook takes
yes there's a small compromise in blacks
position but this bishop looks wonderful
kind of interesting role reversal as
black was the one who had given up at d5
square earlier by playing c5 now we see
that white the one with the backward
pawn on d3 this time with the bishop
controlling not
cheer for white at also 94 very sharp
possibility to try to liquidate down
into what looks like a fairly even
endgame Wow okay so now you have much
more Knight g4 is the most tactically
challenging move and the problem though
is that this move well in fact white is
threatening both knight g6 gen as
maurice has pointed out as well as
Knight f5 and if white just wins the two
bishops and you and black doesn't get
any compensation for it well black is
not going to be happy so is Knight G for
this double-edged move the best response
these exciting lines also by the way 94
the other move here with your 9 under
attack because 96 really looks like it's
liquidating down right way to keep the
fire in the position is to play the move
Knight to f5 exactly now this is hitting
the bishop and the pawn the move Bishop
f6 calmly sidestepping the piece
obviously 90 ace is hit by Knight takes
on f - but now white gets to play the
move rook to e2
guarding your you're not interested in
this pawn on h2 as I know the move f3
and you'll wonder why your Knight study
but rook FD 8 simply guarding the pawn
and preparing the move d5 so answer that
main issue remember you and I can always
go back to e5 as well so no worries for
this Knight and its possibilities this
position is slight advantage of coming
to the engine for white but I'm looking
at it I don't see any real advantage at
all if I had white I wouldn't be happy
playing this position with the white
pieces then Janee gives in fact the move
b3 as the best move to be met by d5 and
how can you possibly give white a real
edge here this just looks like black is
a happy to see the position turn to this
kind of situation so 19:40 lips like a
real reply that magnus and what can he
possibly have you not only that is Fabi
still in his preparation yes
this is scary the fact that the
preparation has gotten so good so
intense the problem is with the
assistance of computers you can just and
I mean I it's Vicky's technique has been
to analyze a position and just leave his
computer on overnight the bottom line to
your answer to your question is yes the
players preparation has gone so deep
they've literally gone from openings to
endings as well so it's possible that by
g4 is still in oh by far I mean it might
even be likely likely over yeah I mean
the fact that after h7 h6 up to this
point
fabbi seems to have played really
quickly in up to and including the move
h6 the move Knight h4 isn't a hard move
to see because it's got to be one of the
key candidates you know you're having
your knight to this square f5 and at
first when you see the move Knight h4
you can go oh no I'm under danger
because Knight f5 96 puts me on my back
foot and you've got roost m Kasim Jon
off sitting next to you and saying no no
everything's fine
because you see you have this really
cool answer Knight g4 oh I do
great yeah and then they feed each other
they keep going and they say okay well
doesn't Knight g6 win and they get
themselves excited and they go right
into it
remember all the details it really
struck me with something their vision on
said is that if you know that the
evaluation is is good for black you'll
figure it out the board like it gives
you some confidence that you're at
you're obviously calculating you Knight
d4 exactly knowing that the position is
good for black no problems
make sure by the way it'll more
confident you know this is not a
position that they looked at in depth in
my opinion like real real depth they
maybe maybe if they stumble upon looking
yeah but when the guy plays Queen a5
well you played Queen a5 and you got
played c4 and you look at it you go hmm
if he wants to play like this then fine
yeah I'll trade on d2 I'll play 8 6
let's take a little bit more stroll down
this position right here
look at a few ideas there anything
dangerous here and you know you might
find your night age for the engine
certainly suggested so you look at it
and you'll find a few moves and I think
this will be an eminently forgettable
line this is one what I mean is easy for
for Fabi to simply forget how the line
goes but know that he's fine because if
he gets here dude if you can't play this
position you have no business being the
world champ because not only is Knight
g4 possible after Knight age four but he
could even just relax I mean he can let
this night land on this square and what
exactly do you have d5 is still being
threatened with affect in this position
what what is you know when you see it
will you look at it you go I should be
okay here you shouldn't be beating me
over the head you only got one little
weakness to point at and you're not
gonna get it for LA cuz really d5 and
solve this problem but maybe put a rook
on da first play d5 this is an easy one
for the saw so I really don't think that
he studied this one that closely because
it just doesn't feel like the test oh
the bus though off the line mature
playing not the sharpest way to play
certainly looked at it but I could see
him forgetting what to do right like you
said I exactly agree with you Jin I can
see him going how does this go again cuz
you got nothing here dude must be fine I
must be fine here the time I'm still
with the test oh and the best oh just a
second hold on Maurice hold on hold on
I'm holding okay I'll go f3 I take on d5
okay Knight takes d5 so wonderful
wonderful wonderful I can post up with
my bishop on e4 I can even post up on my
bishop on b5 okay now I only see night
before as a potential issue and it's
okay let me play I hate to take a waste
our entire move on this but okay a 303 I
want to go G for my next turn I mean
I agree the structure 3 3 3 3 easy draw
right but wait a minute aren't they
playing g4 it's a easy draw what
well maybe we did say he's wrong but my
my major point was if he can't play this
as black and do what he's got to do then
then I mean he's come on you're you're
you should be able to handle your
business in a position but you've got no
real weaknesses the guy's got something
to play for it's not like he's not gonna
play you're gonna play ok but you should
be able to handle your business by the
way the other side of this break we've
got a great guest that's right we've got
Garry Kasparov returning to the show
you're so grateful for that
Thanksgiving weekend is a long one and a
lot to be grateful for but we're gonna
leave you with the fireside chats but
don't turn off the computer monitor
because Gary will you back in just a few
minutes exactly we jump into the modern
age of World Championships we say the
modern age is those you know the driving
thousands was the agent his right was
ancient history but now we talk about
the World Championship with and on first
of all showing how great a champion he
is holding a title down winning it under
various formats exactly which nobody
else has ever done right if it's a feat
a knockout of its matches hesitates and
you name it anon has proven that he is a
true champion time and time and time
again agree and then suddenly comes a
rise of a kid from Norway right and
another force of nature and who would
have thought you're gonna go to Norway
now to go find supreme chess town you
know I mean it's the needle in the
haystack right so toilet gate for all of
its fanciful dress did one thing that
was very very important for a modern age
Maurice and that was it did unify the
world of chess and when the rise of
in Mexico where he wins the world title
with the tournament format the double
round-robin then and bond he wins a
match just a heads up match against
Vladimir Kramnik and he's the guy he's
dama dama dominates the man and then
finally he he now becomes a world
champion but a different kind of world
champion than the world champions we
want and we like we want dominant world
champions we want world champions who
win matches who win tournaments who win
blitz who win everything and this she
wasn't that world champion vichy began
became the guy who concentrated on
winning the million dollar matches he
gets sack and in tournaments and he says
look
bring me my challenger and bring me a
million dollar world championship match
title and while he was playing his match
thing and winning the matches there was
a kid from Norway who became number one
in the world well he wasn't watching so
much Magnus Carlsen who didn't surprise
people so much given that when he was 12
or 13 he was already a grandmaster at 13
and he also played Karpov and beat
Karpov head to head it was a rapid yeah
a game in I think it was Iceland not
Iceland maybe it was I almost be Gary -
you almost be Gary not yet and it was so
cute watching this kid playing Gary
Gary's all intense like this only right
right right and Magnus is like what's
happening on the other yeah where's my
teddy bear teenager and he's a monster
and it's clear and Gary saw it and
everybody saw it that he was coming and
he was gonna be coming on strong right
and he proved it when they 2010 he
becomes number right the world rankings
number one ever yeah and for me I don't
say Magnus is a child of the computer
noon to noon and nothing like that I say
thanks to the Internet this is very very
important you know we now have ax
death to all of the files together
before it was the Soviets had you know
their database has emitter locked away
in the Moscow central chess club
archives and therefore Soviet players
only you and I man you know with no
matter my any kind of money we couldn't
get in there now the internet was the
great equalizer
there was Magnus coming from a country
Norway that has no proud history of
chess none
they had tournaments a had Norwegian
Championships but come on
it was a virtual wasteland compared to
the talent that Magnus Carlsen came from
I mean here suddenly you know this tiny
tiny country relatively speaking in
population five million persons great
dominant force in skiing skiing
competitions I'm betting on the
Norwegian guy in chess competitions I'm
betting on the Russian kid Magnus
Carlsen appears and he also had so much
talent his memory is phenomenally can
remember everything it seems he looked
at games you could just reference and
he's right there
scary shows how chests talent girls so
then he gets to play against a non right
and you and I saw something special here
in st. Louis that's right just before he
goes to play a non we've had
electrocuted the see feel cup yep he's
playing if he draws a game against Levon
Aronian he's the winner wins the
tournament 70k in his pocket right Ronia
offers him a draw that's right audiences
do we say yes and it's over and he
doesn't even have a better position no
fact down upon at the time right I'd
like to play a little fun in play and
you were not like what right you
wouldn't the whole thing the whole money
that showed something special about this
gym absolutely a hundred percent that
was an electrocuting moment for both of
us and I think I haven't fully recovered
from it if I were quite frankly because
the whole point in sporting competition
is one thing victory
you want to win that's it that's and and
you
if you have to win ugly you went ugly
but it's about victory and here victory
was being offered and this young man
magnus carlsen said no i want to play
for a win great confidence great so
unbelievable and we expected him to
transfer to take that into into the
world championship match but the first
three games in that magic later he was
shaky no question real shaky but then he
calmed down a steam room exactly he
reverted to this incredible combination
of abilities that he has the board this
positional grinding tactical awareness
is great tactical awareness this ability
to you know look into your head and say
you're not completely comfortable over
here are you let me just give you a
little sore point as a reminder over
there and you don't like it when this
happens over here so I'm gonna do I'm
gonna ramp it up over here and I'm gonna
put you on the defensive I mean the guy
really any wheels without a loss he also
showed that any position he was willing
to play to the very end the incredible
desire to play every game any percent he
could squeeze out of the position he
would play for and then he wins this
match and dominating style he jumps into
a pool that all his to celebrate and I
think everybody was joyous that we had
this know young champion who was clearer
than one player in the world as well he
defends his match not by the same margin
of dominance against the same Anand yeah
but still showed that the true champion
had arrived and also the highest rated
player of all time the only question for
him is can he keep it up and be the
greatest player ever only time will tell
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to today in chess world
championship edition as we are in the
heat of a game let in Carlson Khurana
but so different than game time yeah
this one minimalistic was the other one
was as wild as a chess game could
possibly be right oh that says I before
we went to break it seemed like there
was a little bit of dissent between you
and Maurice Maurice but inada for Magnus
you were feeling hey this is something
that could be nurse' ball after a few
more moves what's your take as we didn't
see it I do not agree with like about
five steps ahead of me after the move
Knight h4 we saw the move rook e8 we had
been looking primarily at Knight g4 but
rook e8 was a fab ease choice and after
rook e8 came Knight g6 with this very
efficient move Knight g4 takes takes
rookie to defending the pawn on f2 and
suddenly and boringly 95 is about to
produce the bishops of opposite color
middle game position middle gate end
game and game late middle game yeah a
bishops of opposite color position and
not if you lose this you don't belong in
the or championship look this is my far
on drawn the most equal shutting
everything down early game that we've
seen in this match a match that has been
all draws well this is maybe the easiest
one no the easiest no the easiest
definitely the easiest and if I paid a
hundred euros Saturday to come watch
this match and this is what showed up
like feeds I'm sorry you're not happy no
way in the world now of course again
doesn't mean that why it wasn't trying
but this position I mean there's nothing
cuz it's just something here check it
out gen this
b3 is hanging this bishop processing on
me the bishop on d3 is attack the pawn
on c4 is hanging black is going to
either capture on d3 producing like we
say a bishops of opposite color position
the simplest let me just show that on
the board b3 oops Knight takes D three
takes this is the bishops of opposite
color position absolutely Aries launcher
for black to not play this and this and
easy easy draw and what can you really
do if you play let me put another move
on the board Bishop f4 is that a
reasonable move I'm not sure if it is or
isn't and I take on d3 if you take with
the rook I think I can move my rook
again and again this pawn on c4 is
hanging source of counter play so I'm
seeing an easy draw I don't see what
what Magnus can do to avoid that was
Knight g6 necessary there's a little bit
of energy we were trying to prove
something there that made sense but 9jx
did the supercomputer think it was
anything it was shutting me down after
Knight a5 as well
I didn't reflect on look I didn't look
at it at that time right so I won't be
able to tell you but Knight G stone but
certainly 19600 and we have Bishop f4 on
the board Bishop f4 followed by Knight
takes on d3 we're going to see one of
those end games rook d3 has been played
and the rook d7 yeah yeah this is
definitely a draw in the offing they
still have to make 10 more moves what
make us suffer pretend more moves from
this position no draw offer because no
draw loss or or without a repetition got
your move 30 so we will see some moves
but there is nothing here and I can
guarantee you that the journalist will
have some annoying and maybe stupid
questions yes more Magnus after this
game why did you just toss away
last white will be one of them as if he
did it on purpose but that's gonna be
the potentially hostile reception you
get in the press conference yes people
were looking for a game and expecting
something exciting in game 11 to have 11
straight draws to begin a world
championship match is now completely
shattering the record of eight straight
without on in Kasparov and kind of
making you wonder about giving a bad
taste anyway as far as this match is
concerned which some games that have
been really really thrilling but for
game 11 - for the tension to go down in
a way seems a little bit unfair to the
match it it is that strange mixture of
game 10 and there was some really
fantastic
I would love to review oh yeah some of
those moments just as we're gonna review
some of the world championship games
from the women's competition but that
mixture of great chess
followed by some pretty boring
hard-fought boring draws but today's
game it was not a hard fought the other
draws easy at or two draws that we had
before you were mentioning genuine
remember a game that was equal in tedium
to this one the other draws there were
choice that were just like we right
there were draws like that there were
joys that were just like whoa it's
exciting is it not a little some way
game 9 was the game right but if it's
without very quickly under one mistake
after one mistake that's a little
different he had something he was trying
for something he messed it up right this
one is you got just about nothing it
looks small as small you made a quick
you know 9600 I exciting you got a less
than nothing and now you got zero and we
removed 20 and we know it's a draw right
and he knows it's a draw and probably
knows it's a draw and everybody else is
just you know thanks for making on
Saturday short at least here in the US
maybe it's an early dinner for those
watching in Europe but this one is this
one is certainly one of those that the
fans are not
be happy about no and again just
comparing the drawers I still thinking I
believe it was game 10 where MasterCard
Nakamura said well this game will not be
a draw so we have been seeing you know
yeah exactly famous last words indeed
and we do have the situation on the
board bishops of opposite color keep in
mind that in this exact position if you
do end up trading on d6 don't forget
there is a bet I'm not going to take
this pawn on c4 and allow rook oh
actually I can because I just wanted to
say that there is a back rank issue here
whoops so be careful every better to
take the pawn and hope he plays rook and
allow it but we have our special guy yes
we do 13th world champion garry kasparov
has returned to the show to tell us
about what he thinks about this game
Gary yeah your thoughts on today's
battle the most exciting performers play
the radius yes one bishops history I
just you know I thought mangoes will try
this chance you sorry Gary you say that
we say the move Bishop f4 has been
played already yeah yeah and and what
did you I mean I I I should be take on
these three years yes Rahl did you sorry
sorry it's interrupt but the engines
giving f6 as the best move ff6 is the
best move now because my deal was if you
take on this ring yes
I think with the rook yes and after up
d7 yes I bloody Street aha you trying to
make it exciting and after g6 I thought
that maybe it's it's you know why do you
slightly better you take on e6
a good mistakes yeah that's its again F
takes room takes
ting f7 I think who kept six check is
better Giselle is winning car wouldn't
go help courses so you cooking a seven
and then I take my 26 and I think it's
it's yeah maybe King gauge seven is
better yes but but white white suddenly
white you know white has a very strong
initiative
well Gary in no time you got you came on
the show and in 30 seconds from a stone
dry desert you created some cake because
it's been a dry desert f6 and that's
killing my only idea yeah that's it
that's that's the game game is over
drone right Gary disappointed about
today's choice by Magnus
he did play Petrov which is great but he
played a very variant at the petrov that
didn't seem to give him much but it
seems that macros macros struggled from
the very beginning to find something
against petrol that's why he was
switching crowd just to d4 c4 and i
don't think he has any any big idea so
in stock so it's it's it's a natural
choice you can criticize him as much as
you want but it's a world championship
match and he wants to win the match to
retain his title and he's clearly
favorite interrupted so why she should
take any risk now because i do know that
it's about who wins I mean do you
remember that Brazil Italy in you know
the world cup soccer 994 was a scoreless
draw 0-0 and penalty shootout but it
still it stands as Brazil's victory one
of the five victories as the victory
against Italians in 1974 two one yeah at
the end of the day people forget you
know what was the score they were
remember who won the match so that's why
I am here yes to midnight - I would love
to see they're more exciting chairs I
would like to see you know neither from
stead of Petrov but at the end of the
day it's about winning it's a world
championship match you know it's there
you don't expect people yes just you two
to play experiments to please the public
because the public doesn't care if you
play great chess and loss
hey Gary but what about from Magnus's
point of view are you a little bit
afraid on his behalf considering that
the last two times he had black Bobby
really got a big edge it's the is what
was it what you know as we discussed
during your last game so it's it's an
interesting very interesting
psychological woman will fat girl all
the bridges in game 12 considering that
that he is underdog in in rapid or he
will still remember that again draws a
draw and and maybe it's and it will not
take too much risk so I I don't know
definitely there will be a big fight I
don't I don't believe that Bobby will
let it go but how far he's willing to go
it's it's his choice do you think Magnus
is gonna stick with the Sicilian or
switch to double King Fahd I am any fire
it's it's an interesting choice because
my you know experience tells me that you
know when you have one more game to go
you should you probably better go with a
surprise opening but at the same time
you know Magnus knows where father's
going to play against against slashing
so he may decide that you rather stick
with what worked for him there were the
last two games he was in great danger
let's take a look at the current
position although we may not want to but
there's still some life in this position
we will back to where was it the move
back here Bishop f4 93 route d3 rook d7
rook these sakes we saw trades rook d8
and then we saw the move rook to d2
Bishop c4 king c1 b6 and Bishop f4 and
this is where we are so this is the
updated position as we speak with Bishop
f4 and it is tricky for him to trade on
d2 right now because those Queen side
pawns will come under attack
darhk's knows they're all on dark square
so a little bit of life it turns out
trading rooks is not the best idea rook
e8 is the best idea in this position
Gary you said that nobody will remember
that he draw those games well you
remember that Brazil drew in 1990 how
many hours how many how many bill do
remember you know that's that again it's
it's it's in history books you have you
know the winners and losers right I mean
years from now years from now but you
know we live in the immediate age like
instant gratification with Twitter and
Facebook and people wondering about
following a world championship match
will this hamper the next following of a
world championship match of people say
well all you chess players do is just
draw draw draw and nobody wins will that
affect I don't the standards that may
begin certain Corrections are needed I
don't like the idea of extending the
length of the match I think is a stay in
the modern days you know talking about
16 18 games is probably it's not not not
not not the best idea but people won't
know who is the best chess player in the
world they want to know who's the world
champion so I I still believe don't I
mean when I play chess I always wanted
to play great you know exciting
attacking chess but but at the end of
the day the public wants to know who is
the best it's more about sports rather
than about art so that's why I am people
were still following the match between
two best players no matter what form it
is because you know we've we have 11
game this 11th game assume it's a draw
so there's still who they were a few
very interesting games in the match yeah
I could pick up four or five games or
just you know it was quite interesting
towards them and also don't we had this
thing for in in in chess played at is
such high level to win the game it's not
enough to play you know very good chess
you have your opponent to make a mistake
quite a serious mistake and I have to
say that most players they avoided
really big mistakes in this match there
were some you know I missed a specially
game one but you know when you look at
the average quality of their moves is
pretty high and when they one day
they're quite good in defending and just
finding sort of the the
the right moves even under such serious
pressure it's very hard to win I mean
remember game 10 I mean the I think for
almost 10 moves they made they made they
found the best the best ideas for both
sides so Who I am
I'm not with those who are now just
blasting these players for not being for
not being aggressive enough because it's
it's against World Championship match
and the average quality is of the game
which is pretty high average quality do
you think that it would be a good idea
given that you're one of the proponents
of the universal rating system to to do
to maybe add something else as part of
the match like a rapid portion of the
match maybe even in the middle of the
match to rapid games let's say and have
that count and maybe maybe after Game
four you do a couple of rapid games and
after game a you do a couple of rapid
games something maybe it counts for less
or something to to mix up this this
format that of course we've seen as the
classical game has been maintained over
all these years but you do have the
tiebreak now which is a new part of it
at the very end and how that affects
things you think there should be
something to to possibly enliven the
format now by that's again it's a bit
all you know just to either to to
install tiebreak in the middle of the
match it's like you know you there
wouldn't be a tie-break it would be an
article counting game but you it's like
you know you doing that software and and
in the middle of the match so after the
first half you you you you stop telling
the shootouts and then go back look it's
I think we should stick with the
original format because at the end of
the day we'll have plenty of excitement
and rocky chess or if the winner is not
decided then we go to blitz
so they it's at the end of the day they
still have to to tattoo to play much
risk and there will be bloodshed in in
rabbit or bliss so why why should we try
to sacrifice the quality because quality
is pretty good you know this it's that's
very important you know when one knows a
quality not
mistakes we want players just to show
what they you know their best and not
just you know just to make blunders and
for for all bunch of amateurs here now
equipped by by engines you know laughing
loud on the Internet
ya know Gary I understand you completely
as a pure as as a as a lover of chess
I love the classical world championship
match and the content is really great
and the play is on an extraordinary high
level I think that Maurice has questions
are more or less designed to express the
worry that sponsors could be having like
those chess pundits that don't know
enough about chess we're just gonna
criticize and say all you guys do is
play perfect games and you never make
blunders and we're gonna want to see
some mistakes that's why we want to see
blitz and wrap it and mix it up and give
us a reason why we should be spending
millions of dollars for a world
championship match where you produce 12
draws so he's kind of pre-empting some
criticisms that might arise but I agreed
that the match is great the content is
high they play on a really really high
level but at the end of the day the
public's gonna want to see world
champion winning games now it's just
like you said sponsors as well sponsors
as well
so do you see a potential worry is there
any reason to censor you read you you
raised a very very important point
you totally want sponsors now thank you
very much remember 30 years ago when we
reformed grandmas Association we talked
about sponsors you know how to make just
more attractive the chess players so
they they remember they play for the
public not only for themselves yes
perfect yes but but before we before we
worry we should hear a response worried
about so I right now we don't have real
sponsors for us because a gun is just
you know it's it's a it's a name on the
paper
and the money that is being spent on the
World Championship has nothing to lose
commercial sponsors so that comes from
from shadow Russian sources so let's see
what happens if we have the real
sponsors
hopefully this deed is the the chance
that in the next couple of cycles there
will there will I hope it will be
shifted in the right direction and we'll
see what's what would be the reaction I
again I agree that if we if money is
drying is is drying up and no one is
paying and public is is frustrated then
you have to think about changes you see
let's let's you know let's let's see
what happens with this match let's see
dough here out what sponsors going to
say real sponsor see they come in red
let's let's let's hear what public is
going to say so that's I mean I think
that is the reason why chess could could
survive for centuries it's the ability
of our beloved game to adjust demands of
time so I'm quite quite open for any
suggestions that's why for instance I I
believe that Universal rating must
replace and I say must replace you oh
because you cannot separate classical
rapid and blades or even chess960 I
think one day so because it's it's all
chess it's all played by by by the same
rules and you just simply adjust time
control to the number of points you can
gain and since World Championship match
already includes both rabbit and buoys
portion and we had already several world
world titles being decided several more
titles not one some rules are being
decided in in in rabbit and blades or
actual rabbit them it didn't go to bliss
that's far as blades so I think it's
very important that you know we will try
to make it all Universal so it's the I
could dream about day when every game
that is played on this planet even
online will be part of the system
providing you can verify results by by
by making people to justify their
performance by playing not online but
live chess but it's very important that
you know we will create a space where
amateurs you know from Asia Africa
the Mary Cassell day they could be part
of the same global system as magnus
carlsen Fabian Khurana but it's very
important that from the top we see also
changes to adjust to the demands of this
massive massive in some millions and
millions and millions of chess fans
along the world as I understand there
are gonna be changes in the world
women's chess championship in the future
cycle there will be something similar to
what we have in the world championship
what did you think of that match between
Llano Anju and June we've been
discussing it on our show as well I
think that's world champion she's a
better player so that's the it's when
you look at the koalas quality of the
groups she was brought out the heavy
pressure because it's very difficult to
defend your title you know that you want
in the anymore colloquial formats and in
in knockout and I should applaud her
hair a human I mean she survived against
all the odds in in last game for she won
was black and then you know she she she
demonstrated that she has nerves of
steel when it came to to to the tiebreak
so she did it's it's very important and
as a who makes it's all about playing
great chess but in the tiebreak it's
about making fewer mistakes as she did
it well yeah yeah no she did it very
good
by the way we did see a trade of rooks
we did see that the Train the real train
did happen which we suspected after
Bishop f4 rook d2 King D to a six and A
three have been played it's possible to
pick up this c4 pawn a c5 pawn but if if
you go for it for example let's before
this let me just go right here if you go
for it in this position before a three
after a six then black is able to gain a
temp sorry Bishop here black is able to
gain a tempo with this move and then
play for c4 the King starts to march in
then this move Bishop to e4 his to see
to pawn it makes it very difficult for
the kids leave or as Morris Morris
Morris can I tell you that is it's after
Bishop d6 blacks can take on a two as
yes nothing on day two that's why he
played after age 6 that is Bishop c7 he
played Bishop c7 that you should be six
it can take a 92 that way b3 happens c4
c4 also comes into position before not
after before sister each egg and block
you know after before C's recheck and
block that's they that's the easy draw
which is actually Maurice confused me
because I didn't understand the move a
six
I thought Bishop takes a two immediately
Fabiano after the trade of rooks could
have just captured the pawn did I miss
something it's probably probably the
ghost official Spassky game water yeah
[Music]
Bobby Fischer getting his Bishop trapped
was was classic but there were bishops
all of this of the same color so yeah
yeah so that's and that's that's why
Bishop was trapped on h2 and here is
easy draw yes
no anyway back up back up right yes
that's yes ah that's a that's a Greek
that is the trick that would be lorina
aha so Bishop takes a - yeah okay
so that's why we did see the movie a 6 a
3 because Bishop a two eventually is
going to be a threat yes okay and here I
well this looks to me to be pretty
pretty even Stephen I don't know 5 is
better no because then you can go to e4
if he forces you hi you like the bishop
on the DS because if you buy Bishop d6
because it doesn't matter father just
doesn't matter and then you start
bringing your black King there so this
thing I don't see what what what one can
do the point here is Bishop b4 Bishop b4
really convinces you you know
you're not going to try to tickle the
guy when you drop the c2 part mmm yeah
Gary we've seen this mixture of some
really fascinating draws and today's
game which well let's be frank we think
of it as a boring draw your take over
all your take of the match the games
what inspires you and what do you think
about the preparation of the players is
the preparation just too good yeah
Fabiana definitely was well-prepared so
and and don't forget you know what what
we normally see at the board is probably
10% or 20% of what has been prepared
because they always prepared for
different scenarios so you could be no:1
going ahead you could be you could be
trailing so you always have to to be
ready to change changing your strategy
if the situation of the match has
changed in your favor or against and it
seems to me that Magnus had no big ideas
for the match so it's and he decided
wisely I mean just not to not to take
too much risk and just you know to stick
with with whisky's real strengths which
is to apply for so small small edge and
just you know keep playing and trying to
use them even minimal advantages or some
hesitations of these opponents what is
now working against bangers in this
match is that Fabiano is as we discussed
it last time is extremely stable you
could feel it so that's the even if even
in the game changes if it suddenly
happens during the game he's not
panicking so it's a game time was very
important because it was it was just you
know up and down so that's the game and
you could see you could feel that Robbie
even while I would argue about
mousse-like g3 that he made it was still
not in control but you know he was not
losing it so as the which is you know I
think quite depressing format
so that's why you could feel that he's
getting nervous and what happened at the
end of the game 10 it's it's a it was
just you know quite a probably Sandro
magnet like King before and you know
putting his game at great risk it was
still a draw but all of a sudden you
know instead of having little pressure
oh he has to find the only moves to
survive so I think that Bobby's
preparation both psychological and chess
preparation they may bangles feel more
vulnerable I'm shocked when you say
Magnus came into a match with no big
ideas I mean he is team had months to
prepare for once he found out in March
it to play against Fabi they must have
had they must have had some stuff some
bullets in the gun to be able to shoot
at this guy and yet they've shown time
and time again that nothing they have
thrown at him has bothered him is it
that he may have had some ideas but
Bobby just control the match because
it's hard to believe he spent all these
months this is it's not about time you
you can spend on your preparation it's
also about your determination it's about
your creativity and I think your Magnus
played already quite a few more
championship matches so it's the and he
can play confess himself that is you
know running out of steam so it's the is
still phenomenal player I give him you
know much better odds in in in rapid if
it goes there so and I think it's yes
again good chance of surviving a lot the
last game was black but you know we
already saw it in these matches Kuryakin
so he the trend when you look at Magnus
games and last at all most units let's
say from 2010 when he became number one
by rating
he is it has been shifting you know from
from very aggressive approach in the
opening to more you know technical aside
so let's get a little bit you know here
there and keep building this advantage
so it's minimizing risk and if that's a
style it's very difficult to change it
over a few months so when you prepare
your strategy for the match you always
think about your strengths and I think
Magus felt uncomfortable of doing
something that could contradict his his
modus operandi this is in my books and
lectures I kept talking about you know
the gravity of past success and we are
seeing now that is free madness cases
the gravity of mass success it has been
working for so long and now trying to
change it and going back to more
aggressive approach it's just making
psychologically uncomfortable
that's incredible given that he's only
just turning 28 at the end of this month
is that doesn't make separate Tiger
Woods when he changed his swing even
though he was on top of the world and he
spent a year and a half two years
changing his swing doing worse in golf
tournaments and people are saying well
why did you bother to change your swing
you're the best in the world and then
finally when they swing kicked in then
he was even more dominant than he was
before
is it possible at the tender age of 28
to change to maybe start being more
aggressive over the next year and a half
just to change things up and maybe grow
from that as a player or is it too late
for him already okay it's the again it's
all about tender age it's about number
of years you are on call and it's and
it's it's eight years it's almost a
decade and and and he established his
style and he has been working I mean
let's be emphasize if it works it's very
difficult to move and do something else
you mentioned Tiger Woods but you know
he was you know he was that's why he
stayed on top for so long because he
could feel competition coming a
competition coming this is this wagon a
new challenge is coming and and he
always wanted to be at the cutting edge
and to be one step ahead mangoes when
this is trying you know yeah I don't
blame him for not trying but
psychologically is extremely difficult
because it has been working and and he
has expected that you know he could he
could play this match you know using
this old technique because at the end of
the day if it's six six he he believed
that he would be favored in rabbit again
it's about winning the match and
mangos counts his World Championship
victories and at the end of the day he
will be happy to you to collect it even
if we decided a bliss thank you so much
Gary for joining us yeah what a
wonderful conversation sorry that the
game wasn't as thrilling as you guys the
26 yes and then I'm sure you know that's
why by the time we'll meet and do 26 the
game will not be will not be at the
final stage you know just opposite color
bishops I agree with your prediction on
that Gary I think we're gonna have
another wild wanna for game 12 so we
can't wait for you to join us then thank
you so much and see you on Monday
championship Monday thanks Gary
thank you very much Maurice although
fabbi has been thinking
it really looks horribly boring I mean
this is really really sad because we
have this great player Gary Kasparov
coming to join us we want to test him
and and show us some really great for
chess fans let's talk about five Magnus
fans what chess fans this is not what we
paid our money for oh sorry we didn't
pay anything for the race even so we
showed up earlier this morning excited
about game 11 it was gonna be punchy so
wait wait what do you mean that they're
like standing on the other side of the
Ring how you doing as you put it yes
throwing marshmallows from 50 feet yeah
does this hurt I mean this is just a
snooze fest this game easy liquidation
no attention again Magnus is definitely
trying to win the match that's clear
right not trying to lose the match yeah
in the opening that's clear he needs to
make a draw tomorrow at least yeah he
could still win but explain
tation is that he's gonna come under
pressure from Fabi there's gonna be some
opening prep Fabia shown in the last two
games he wants to sharpen the game he
wants to sharpen the battle will he over
press Magnus might be doing it Aikido
style you come at me too much because
you feel you need to win this game and I
was punish you for for over pressing
that could be another part of his
strategy so really the situation favors
him going forward likely big draw window
with the black pieces and then he might
be able to just take it all in the rapid
for rapid games against the number one
consensus best player on the planet in
rapid you've got to beat me in a four
game rapid match good luck with that
so he is looking at these rules and
saying and if we do do wrap it then we
played blitz games where I'm even better
than you even further ahead than you are
so all these numbers right here his team
maybe maybe even if Magnus said but I
want to beat him in a classic all his
team said but you would own him in the
tiebreaker why bother
I mean look at these numbers number one
in the world in a rapid versus number
ten in the world that's an edge may not
seem that much but look at the blitz
difference number one versus number
eighteen in the world I mean if you you
might be a Fabian but if I told you
let's bet the house hits a take take my
chips over here please
hello we know who the favorite is here
so that's what you got to look at as
Magnus's key strategy moving forward we
should put the odds at for tomorrow's
game he had some interesting odds that
he yeah he said on just twenty four that
it's eighteen percent no 22 percent five
you an 18 percent mangas win 60 percent
of draw what do you think about that's
obviously that sounds like a high
decisive percentage concerning what
we've seen so far right I think there's
a 40 percent chance it because of
greater risks tomorrow there's gonna be
blood on the board well actually I think
he's right and you you had mentioned it
okay if I said to fabbi a month ago okay
you're gonna really study and you're
preparing for this man
fabbi it's gonna be a great match it's
really really contested not after 11
games the match is tied five and a half
five and a half it's coming down to the
final classical game and you get white
are you gonna sign up for that right now
and he's got to say sure you know I
thought Magnus to a standstill I get
white in the final game I'm close to a
tie break where I understand I'm an
underdog but he's got to be happy with
with this current situation happy I
think he has to be he is that upon right
now by the way because make that point
he didn't lose his pawn this he
jettisoned he just went into a3 King f8
Bishop c7 b5 Bishop d6 check I think he
thinks that he's got an easy draw in
this position Bishop takes pawn here h5
King to e3 and I believe King d7 was the
last move played it is a three against
two on this side but no real progress
it's impossible to create a passed pawn
on this side of the board with this
three against three
so as long as his king is over here he's
gonna be blockading the pawn he's
decided very practically he didn't have
to go for this inferior position but
he's decided from a practical standpoint
this is a draw this yeah he's nola dread
dog dead draw he's gonna make it a just
a stone cold roar bring the King to this
side and you you can't even bother any
you can't do any pawn formation
construction to bother this once this
pawn it's g6 that's going to be simply
impossible to do so everything that
happens here will be trades of pawns you
can't create a passport in some weird
way nothing there's no way to make this
three overcome this three with this
bishop sitting guarding this f7 point so
as long as the King stays here this
shams be a clean room can Magnus try in
this position Maurice the one you've got
f3 g4 and try to get it past H pot yeah
yes like f3 g6 go ahead good play g6 and
g4 and here you shouldn't be taking
exactness exactly I mean how do you
even here how do you break down the
position because your f3 pawn would
always be a problem right so how what do
you what is your plan if I just sit
still I'm gonna like yeah I was just
saying later this bishop will harass
this pawn or paint rice today although
let's say I win this let's try a couple
of moves I'm gonna play black King c6
King oh I've just lost well you don't
want to hang your [ __ ] I don't want to
get my bishop okay so King c6 Bishop FA
let's play let's play King back to d7
King right or else we came back to c6
and let's take now take King here and
there should be two takes takes here by
far that you you really help white a lot
yeah I just by even allowing in my past
HP exactly so right so what is this
position about because King g5 now he is
trying to get this pawn to h6 again here
somewhere and and your King in the
meantime unfortunately for you yeah this
position is not so easy because this
King is gonna pick this one off guys and
it should be liquidation on this side
right so let's play some moves like this
one this one this one I look like I'm
fast King here okay fair enough
oh wait there is a there is a way
there's this one mmm we have to be
mindful cuz c4 well how can this be
right if I take C for King takes a three
they say three King before C five Kings
the farm is king before and that's weird
but wait because you do have to worry
about this pawn but is there a temp oh I
have this move no of course I don't have
that move this is cool is there c6
thinking f5 oh I have this before yeah I
have this move yeah to push the King
this way to hit the bishop and force the
bishop to decide which diagonal to
defend right and now all the trouble
stars yes so somehow we can lose this
position if we construct it in the wrong
way possible to lose this position but
that's all a big effort that's a lot
that was a lot of help
yeah yeah definitely helped white as
much as possible to get to that
situation but my father when he first
got to f4 in the line when the Paul was
on g4 when he first got to fo sure to
play Bishop e2 yeah I'm King that I get
it should be king in four yeah once that
Bishop e2 I'd have to create it again
King d7 you will it was f3 king c6
Bishop debate g6 GT or King back and
then you went king f4 and now play this
one right that was keeping me honest I
can't select again so like this and do
this because of that right and that's
how you just stop all this down yeah
that's enough just call this position so
Jennifer there's a there's no sir
there's no draw before 30 moves but you
reckon draw is in the offing here a draw
offer is in the offing no I don't think
you you throw first time control 40
bucks because I mean because what we've
just seen with Maurice I mean white even
playing a poor version
you got no chances of winning true but
how can they please I feel like they
played some positions kind of our well
there was that bishops where that the
bishop ending of opposite color work
Matt got to pass pawns
I think it's so did fabbi and then
fabbi just waited waited Magnus played
like 12 moves moved the skiing around
said okay I got yeah yeah I predict
something similar to that actually play
it out to like 4550 boos okay because
yeah I really do think so okay I'm
seeing g7 well I'm seeing g6 I'm seeing
king c6 and then I'm seeing that black
is just waiting you can never move with
your king up to the g5 square because
you'll leave your King sight pawns
exposed and I'm thinking about game 10
where Fabiana was a pawn up in a rook
ending rook and three versus rook into
politely offered
draw from the better position and Magnus
said sure and I think this is just one
of those where it's not even close
Maurice over to you let's take a look at
the Women's World Championship match to
see how they ended up with all the
similar draws as well first let's start
with this game sorry I went to the
second one before let me just get this
right why does it keep going to 6.6 like
he doesn't want to show me the draw for
6.5 there we go finally all right so
this end game which looks a lot richer
than the one we're looking at now but an
opposite color Bishop ending as you see
here this was the first rapid game that
they played and it ended up in this
situation King g3 Bishop a5 King g2 and
they repeated and got this draw no way
to break through opposite call the
bishop pawns on the other colors you see
that just was not possible to make any
progress so this was their first rapid
game that ended in a draw the second
rapid game which all right take my
fingers are small enough all right we
jumped to another position and look at
that opposite colored bishops in the
second rapid game despite white being up
a pawn unable to overcome her opponent
with Katarina like no here because it's
just obviously colored issues and we
know unless you have other advantages
you're not going to be able to make any
kind of hay because you need a passport
on the other side or at least have the
pawn if you get to an extra pawn you
need to be separated by two files that's
the book concept you need the separation
so that the king and the bishop cannot
guard both pawns by themselves or
together as a unit by separating them
then one is forced to guard one pawn and
then the other you just overwhelm so
this was a second draw of bishop
opposite colors two games in a row we
had that now the third game now we're at
the ten plus ten and this game was
critical because it was the first win
that appeared in the tiebreak and if we
go down to the critical moment it was
here take a look at this one sharp
opening play led to this position
white was Katarina like no black was Jew
engine and all she had to do here what
Katarina was play Bishop takes b2 and
we'd have an opposite
colored bishop position again for the
third game in a row and it would be an
easy draw and then she would fight it
out in the fourth game she did have
black she would have black in the fourth
game guaranteed so instead she said you
know what I got the two bishops I don't
want to draw
why should I trade opposite colored
bishop and made this mistake Bishop f1
trying to maintain the two bishops and
over looked at this forward thinking
move Knight d1 and all of a sudden she
looked and realized oh no I'm losing my
f2 pawn and Bishop e3 doesn't help
because of Bishop takes on e3 and then
Knight captures that Knight gets out by
the way I did check and you'll have a
knight and extra pawn against a bishop
that's not an ending you want to play in
blitz she kept playing she had her
drawing chances even then but she didn't
defend very well ended up losing this
game and costs her the first game of the
10 + 10 now she had to win the final
game and pulling this one up she got
into this position where no advantage
for either side even material nothing to
play for and in a situation where she
was desperate trying to win she made a
horrific blunder queen g6 and after
Knight takes g6 that's all she wrote two
games down for the match match was over
and Jew engine remained champion 2018
champion twice's make that square
because she won back in May and again in
November rightful reigning champ and
still the champ Jew engine Grand Master
from China she has had a fantastic year
add the fact that she won the gold medal
in the Olympics the goal cousin you as
the best performer for the women in the
Olympics and she captain the Chinese
women to that gold medal which they join
their fellow countrymen who won in the
open section so China has a lot to cheer
for this year on the tournament circuit
juin join once again a deserving
champion for 2018
haven't gotten enough of London guys
we've got another her offend coming up
that we're gonna be doing exclusive
commentary for 11th to 17th in December
is the London chats classic the grand
chest tour finals we have two Americans
in the final he Kuro Nakamura and
Fabiano Carolina who could be the world
champion as he pleased for the first
grand chest tour title with this finale
structure right so there's been this
will be the first year that we have
qualifiers even to the final in addition
to Fabian de Caro there is LaVon and
Maxime will also be playing a match yeah
and those will be the semi-finalists the
two Americans matchup in the semi-final
so there will be an American the final
and I think after all of the Cara's
comments about who he's predicting this
World Championship I think fabiana's
during the match but after the match
people tell it you could be sure I'm
gonna ask him yes I get to London and do
a little pre match mvl and Levon are
good buddies amazingly
it's hard to get them to say bad things
about each other but they wanna bash
each other's head in especially Levon
he's always said it's always good to
beat your friends but Fabien and
Nakamura no love lost there and I think
that we will certainly want to hear from
Fabi you know his feelings on the fact
that his his countrymen was predicting
the other guy to win I actually like
what Levon was during this World Cup so
in the World Cup finals he's playing MVL
and they said to Levon you know like
well gee Levon you know you're playing
your really good friend MBL how do you
feel about it he says what do you mean I
hate him I hate them all
tongue-in-cheek of course but nice as
you were giving as a retrospective of
the Women's World Championship I did
want to mention once again that that
game team was great and I just like to
relive a couple of moments from the I've
ever called live I mean obviously it's
hard to say how much that was due to the
stakes but I do think it was actually
the most exciting night and there were
just a couple of moments that we really
didn't get a chance to get into the
given the fact that I had a free day and
I could just look at it at my leisure I
was like wow here a crucial position a
crucial position we had Vichy on the
line and this was where g2 g3 was
essayed by fabbi because he saw that
after this last move Queen g5 by the
world champion with the idea of a rover
rook up and over to the Kings side
whether it be the h6 where the g6 square
block White's King was going to comment
under considerable pressure
fabbi wanted to shut down the attack
with g3 Vishy Anand who was on the line
said go ahead call his bluff Bishop
takes b5 rook up rook rook over and drop
your Bishop back you can do it fabbi
grab the poles align by the way we
should point out that that was really
interesting their continued continue in
that variation which ones that omission
b5 yeah okay sorry
rook at six rook e1 rook rook GA rip t6
to g6 sorry yep one bishop f1 and now
Bishop to g4 right Bishop to g4 and this
is something that you might have worried
about them of f3 yes and takes yes and
pawn takes is possible yes a Rick takes
is also possible as possible because
Bishop f3 looks like it's winning
potentially but that Bishop on g1 guards
the g8 the g1 squared Bishop zombie six
guards the g1 squared
excuse me I guess
the second regards that Square and maybe
that could have been something you
overlooked is Bishop sitting on that
square maybe too dangerous a position to
walk in to force him to sock in exchange
well you certainly don't expect the
bishop that's sitting way over there on
the queenside be six to play a crucial
role in your defense right on the Kings
side okay very very crucial moment in
the press conference
fabbi said here he spent so much time he
saved the move g3 but later he
explaining that well he regretted that
he didn't also play f3 and Magnus
pointed out well if you play f3 the
intention was to play like this and
after takes Queen h4 Bishop takes III
looks like you're two pawns up what's
the problem you're about to play the
move rook F to completely shut down
blacks attack not so fast black to move
black makes a draw with a beautiful
Queen sacrifice check and check with the
rook now don't even think about trying
to escape with King f2 because Jim a gen
happy the other way I'll take it check
and mate to White's King white would
actually have to acquiesce to a draw a
perpetual by the repetition the next
thing that really threw me off and I
didn't realize this is that as they got
into this endgame just towards the time
control right here fabbi ended up making
the time control with seconds on his
clock yeah it was down to like final six
when he made the move 40 and I didn't
realize at the time they got under this
double edge position right here that the
time was such a crucial factor can be a
tricky trap exactly no they got to this
position where Magnus had just laid two
incredible
juicy cheapos that he was hoping that
fabbi would fall for that
actually played the beautiful move rook
e1 but it was really under pressure
exactly it was really easy to fall for
this materialistic trick of Queen b3
check now notice that blacks queen stuck
in White's camp is attacking the rook on
d1 now once you see the move c4 which
not only protects the rook on d1 but
also attacks black's Queen you go oh my
god that's Queen is trap I'm winning I'm
winning until you see the move Rope
takes b6 and you go oh I'm not winning
it's a draw
rook takes e to cook takes b3 rook takes
e4 it's a draw until you see that guy
doesn't take your queen he sacrifices
his Queen he takes on e 2 and after
Queen c2 Murray's you saw this rugby to
baby and white loses okay so yeah I take
and take on f2 that's right Queen and
I've got a passer okay we were gaining a
tempo by playing repeat too because
that's where we want our wrong exactly
but there was another and nasty cheapo
champions were the bet pop woman to
player in history I heard that Jude it
was when analyzing this position she was
having trouble taking the white side
right she wanted to play vibe she
spotted for a lot of these traps exactly
now another easy trap to fall for which
fabbi avoided grace under pressure as
you said was Queen D for defending the
rook on b2 and the rook on d1 and you
think okay III c4 and once again blacks
Queen is trapped
fabbi is winning right
oops not until you see this
leaving the Queen on free not only that
but allowing a roof take situ in Queen
d5 Jack yeah rookie to Queen d5 check
look at that rooks galore hanging oops
on the seventh ranked f3 takes e to a
princess party what we must laugh
because the players were in time to
catch up and once I reflected on all of
these great lines I thought that myself
that'd be played an unbelievable well
both of them I mean I think the fact
that Magnus saw all these tricks favi
rebutted all of them
it's truly astonishing it really like as
gary said those last 10 moves the fact
that you can play such great moves under
under so much time pressure and mental
pressure it makes you kind of wonder
when people are saying oh they're gonna
crack under the nerves to the contrary
it seems like they're actually playing
like superhuman in some ways no it's
crazy the opposite can easily happen and
that's why we see so many draws and I
want to give a big shout-out to
mvl for his annotations at chess calm
and alerting me to some of these lines
that was really really really pretty
I'm sure MPI was also having fun with
black yes
over to you Maurice what has happened in
this current game 11 are you like me
expecting a draw offer shortly I love
those lines though could we go back to
48 hours ago
yes I'm start talking about that stuff
because this here is just nothing going
good it's just they already know they
already know they're making moves but
they already know especially since white
is about to be forced to put is all
these pawns on dark squares that's right
that's gonna happen because he just
can't leave this pawn alone his King is
tethered to it as this Bishop keeps
harassing it first 21 now it's going to
go to f5 and do that and now he's
decided to play the move c4 which will
create liquidation on this side for sure
and once that happens and this pawn is
still going to come under fire and his
key
he's gonna have to sit there look at
that he actually played this way
doesn't matter because he can leave his
King here on d4 and the trade could
happen doesn't matter how you play this
the Queen side will be liquidated and
you cannot make that passport happen on
this side with any kind of security this
is just wrong this is wrong you can keep
it exciting they're making moves now to
figure out how do we make this draw they
might even get to move 52 B Frankie
might even get to move 50 is here well
we didn't play a 30 move Joe a 20 move
draw don't even try it
we see what happened here here's a
question for you guys if you're a
reporter what question do you ask Magnus
today because it's hard right I mean
after what he said we were joking about
what he said to the reporter who asked
him at what point did you realize it was
draw and he's like when it was a draw I
know he's disappointed yes of course
very and I wasn't used all actually
tweeted that if you were there on the
scene some people might think that Oh
Magnus is trying to draw out to the
tiebreak but he says no no no this
really is looking like Magnus is doing
in NYC and forgotten he has a black to
survive but from doing an unwise new
meaning trying to draw the last two
games to get to the city to tiebreaker
that game yeah but from seeing his face
I would say that there's some
combination of bad prep banners and a
bad decision mm-hmm well maybe the bad
was only about the bad press but Magnus
not happy no by the way that would be
the question no not the bad problem
question the question although you don't
want to irritate the guy but that's the
real question that you should be asking
is why after six months you don't you
have a solution or an antidote to the
Petrov you try when I ask the direct
questions I get in trouble but no the
question I was saying was are you are
you now in a phase as you were in the
last
match of trying to draw out the last two
you know I think that question is gonna
get you in more trouble okay the answer
must be no because he knows yeah that
Bobby's gonna gonna go for it with white
tomorrow he knows he's gonna be under
pressure of course so it's like just
think it's impossible for the answer to
be yes like I can't see a logical
universe in which magnets could ever
think that it was a good idea to draw
this game with with white and then in
the next game you know up against the
wall maybe it happens you know it
happens and that's unfortunate but if
there's no way that was his intention
let me just trade off the pieces and
draw with white agree that would be dumb
I agree wholeheartedly Jennifer Maurice
I thought that you and Gary were having
a very interesting exchange where Gary
was actually making the suggestion at 28
years old that Magnus is a little bit
tapped out that he doesn't have enough
energy original ideas competitions
catching up to and I think he also was
saying trending has trended for so long
in what has made him successful that
he's not that he's not really almost
incapable of flexibly changing and I
that I found very surprising to me
because 28 does not seem even it seems
28 young 10 because he said you know
he's been he's been successful for the
last eight years almost a decade he's
been at the top and this has worked so
because all this has worked I I'm just
I'm just not gonna change that I'm not
comfortable enough trying to change it
seems to me that he could spend the next
year and be willing even to let let go
of the reins for a little while I'm not
gonna be number one maybe for a while
because I'm gonna maybe have some bad
results right change on my own but Gary
himself with one of the great quotes
I've heard him say you know you're
becoming a better chess player when you
change your openings right you challenge
yourself challenge yourself are you
saying that because he's been so
successful that there's a part of Magnus
as simply unwilling to challenge himself
and try to do something afresh even if
it means losing a few games looking like
the less invincible self but in a year
from now having grown so much and now
suddenly a variety this variety to his
stop but the guy's a freaking genius
let's get it straight right he's so
stuck in what he's done that he can't
change I mean Gary knows more than we do
about the top the top of level chess I
just found that really yeah surprising
it was exciting because when I listened
to Gary talk about it it felt like it's
destiny for five Yano Carol de Winne it
feels like if this was a movie Bobby's
gonna win tomorrow or even dare I say
when you get that because the way Gary
was talking it sounded like you know an
arc a story but as we know chess is not
a movie and if a lot of it's about the
odds and the math and the probabilities
as well when you look at it's the sport
as as gary said so exactly but the way
he was talking it was like yeah what's
gonna happen but if this was a rocky
series yeah Bobby would win this game
game last game and then there would be
Magnus the sequel where it's Magnus 2.0
and he please coming back stronger
maybe maybe all the same grinding skills
but a little bit more aggressive in some
of the openings right so like when he
was when I was hearing was talk I was
like projecting the next ten years an
favi world champion Magnus comes back
stronger Wow in America I got my
imagination activated right I just I
just found it really remarkable for
myself when I heard Murray's and Gary
talking about this 28 year old as being
this wily old veteran who's a little bit
tapped out of ideas and that's
incredible I just thought well we'll
wait a minute why isn't he gonna go on
and have another you know brilliant
you're like you Gary dominated chess for
20 years I thought that was every story
for you Bobbie winning somehow she's a
team member player yeah Wow I really
believe in challenging oneself yeah
making changes constantly making changes
never resting on your laurels do what is
successful but even when you're
successful look for ways to grow and
it's very hard for me to believe that
Magnus just is simply anti change and
thinks that if he if he slips a little
bit and it's not number one anymore that
it's going to matter so much it's gonna
be the end of the world
mm-hmm and that he's only gonna keep
doing what he's been doing when it in
all the face of it says he now has been
caught by Fabi look at their rating
they're three points apart right losing
rating points with all these drugs may
be a strange infraction grandmasters
murdered who said that if there was a
300 game match and they drew all them
Bobby would overtake Magnussen reading
by four well yeah because he's supposed
to go plus water games Tony Rich's
calculations so it's a fraction it's
always raining no matter what it's a
tiny mind time yeah it would be
something like a tiny tiny fraction I
think you wouldn't even see it on the
number list will be like 25 34 and
they're both equal at 25 34 something
like that because it'd be twenty five
thirty four point zero two versus point
zero one something that miniscule but
he's been caught by Fabi in terms of
performance that's right Shaq is right
behind him
I think you're always right in ding
Lorena's is waving hey guess what guys
I'm I'm right in the next door all right
I'm coming you know it used to be that I
was down the block around the corner
and now I'm close I'm about to open the
gate watch out so he's seen that and
he's got to be thinking what do I need
to do to become its it to be even more
enlivened by the game fresh again do I
need to add to some spark some dynamic
more dynamic openings or do I need to
just sit and do what I've been doing and
try to do it incrementally better you
know I'm a proponent of change is good
change is the right thing to do it just
sparked so much new energy makes you
embrace a new challenge freshens the
mind allows for growth that's that's
what I believe in and I find it hard to
believe and I believe in it at that 28
38 48 50 you name it keep going
change is good don't just sit down and
get old 28 is old no way come on a new
age I know no way come on exactly
exactly and the some marvelous quote by
Woody Allen that goes like that if
you're not challenging yourself your
remaining too often in your comfort zone
it's something some something like that
that you've got to be able to challenge
yourself by the way I think we're gonna
go on break gin because I'm just looking
at this game I don't see a draw-off for
being right then 50 moves you were
definitely stand corrected break though
because wait the conclusion of game 11
of the World Chess Championship
[Music]
st. Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st. Louis
Slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015
SLU partner with the st. Louis chest
look to start a top-tier collegiate
chess team on the very first year of the
team's inception Slough obtained second
best university at the pan-american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University a moment comes in chess when
you need to test yourself at a different
level chess 24 premium offers the tools
that you need to reach your maximum
potential from hundreds of interactive
video lessons to becoming part of the
chess 24 community you can analyze with
friends or coach your students live you
get twenty four by seven coverage of
chest news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership
health care in America is changing
evolving and we're helping lead the
transformation ascension is made up of
physicians and other caregivers called
to deliver compassionate personalized
care for all as one of the largest
providers of care in the country our
patients benefit from collaboration
between hospitals medical practices and
healthcare innovators nationwide
ascensions faith-based heritage means we
have a moral obligation to serve
everyone especially those who are
struggling last year we provided almost
two billion dollars in care for people
living in poverty and for programs to
help them whether it's in a hospital a
neighborhood clinic a senior living
facility or at home ascensions care
providers value every aspect of our
patients lives and health we listen with
respect to ensure every person we serve
gets the right care for them
personalized compassionate that's
Ascension
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our World
Championship coverage of a Carlson
Carolina we're in game 11 and it looks
like we have another draw yes as
expected
Magnus did he get anything today he
didn't get anything and it was this
final wide in the classical portion of
the match it means there is one game
remaining with a match tied five and a
half five and a half and in that final
game which will be played on Monday
Jennifer it will be the Challenger
Fabiano with the white pieces and the
winner wins or we're gonna have a tie
break the heat that Robbie is and this
team has brought in the last two whites
I mean you got a figure Magnus's next
two evenings might not be too was it not
as easy as it was in New York City when
he had the white pieces in the final
game because he will be up against it
and that preparation Maurice you gotta
give the preparation edge to fabbi
absolutely that's been the case
basically the entire match it's clear
who the better prepared player has been
as far as the opening is concerned but
openings don't win games I mean unless
you come up with a novelty just bust the
guy and it's completely over you still
got to finish him off
and magnets are shown to be incredibly
resilient truly a defensive player and
being able to show that a I can draw I
can still make a draw even if you get
good positions so far he's gonna have to
play with elan with energy with
determination and will he even play with
that our word a four-letter word to him
has been risk will he go for it the way
he could have gone for it in the last
game taking on b5 and taking a chance
here we've seen him so far just hesitate
in some games where we really felt like
hey it press here he's just been a
little bit of hesitation but it's one
game for the money I mean one game you
get white if you had a set to Fabiano
before this match started you get one
game you get white you win the whole
thing I think he would have signed up
for that against Magnus he has
I've been really tested with the black
pieces his team right now I can be
patting themselves on the back because
they did the job they weathered all
storms with white
well storms maybe more like a mild
breeze blowing because he's been able to
show his stuff with black every single
game essentially holding his own now
it's time to get it done as we have a
score of five and a half five and a half
after 11 no wins 11 draws to start a
world championship that is a record by
far maybe when we will not see again for
a long time will he be able to deliver
it in the last game I will Magnus show
that he can deliver as well as he's won
last games to win matches by the way
let's make a good point about that
Magnus is after all be world champion
Maurice if you just pull up the final
part of game 11 because Magnus did set
certain traps just at the final stages
but Faby avoided the tricks go ahead and
show us what were some of the tricks
that Magnus had laid but were
ineffective well I know you were really
excited about this position still
talking about this game but yes but
should be to king e7 Bishop to b3 King
f6 mr. BAE to anybody this move f5 right
and 5 trying to sacrifice his pawn so
you can at least hit his H pawn rolling
and down the board and after Bishop to
b1 which he was a serious danger right
temporized even one more move and said
go ahead take with your bishop you want
to take with the pawn take with the
bishop well of course Bishop takes would
walk into the move h5 and suddenly that
you cannot capture there goes your
bishop in this position and the pawn
will get 286 and then all of Norway
would be smiling at that little trick
but of course Fabi was just too cool for
school played Bishop to c2 and said
nothing's changing here you've got
nothing you know I know you've got
nothing this is just the draw and then
the whole point is if Magnus had
continued with the move King takes f7
then you can play Bishop takes f5
because there's no H fight Rick they're
not tickling the bishop correct
yeah yeah I know it was all about you
know I love how you get excited about
little nuances like that yeah I can
trick my opponent these guys are just
too good Maurice
they see I think I think that a lot of
people are too good for those tricks
yeah no no before I think Oh God which
one's easier to miss yes oh that was so
good Queen b3 it's harder that's harder
yeah the Queen b3 check followed by c4
that is so oh that's so awesomely bad I
mean to fall for that trap because it
looks like you're winning you're just
trapped like I like that one
I like that one of the only thing I can
say that it might have tipped Bobby off
is that it's not missing Queen be free
and exactly you're the math girl we'll
work it out for us
what should that be do for game 12 again
we're gonna have a free day and Monday
before you've been getting tons out of
these fashion acosta zillions I think
what team Bobby is showing that this
session to cut Sicilian it's very rich
for white yes and we can you've got a we
have so many targets right so it's not
just like this linear thing where we
can't find deviations they found two
deviations that gave way too big edge
I'm scared if I'm Agnes you should beat
you and before those are the deviations
I feel like there's a number three in
there somewhere
there's a number three and that might
cause Maggie to switch to double King
Bond but that has some perils of its own
because that's the stuff then there's no
information that yeah you have no idea
what's gonna happen and that kind of
excites me as well though I'd actually
prefer to see another Sicilian I'm also
kind of like curious about this like a
mini match that we have one game in the
double King pawn after the six five
Sicilian right um what's your prediction
well for me I was really surprised at
the special knock off the second time
around I thought that Magnus was
seriously scared that first time with
Bishop d2 and a five so I thought he was
going to be chased into the
King pong defenses I didn't think that
fabbi was going to get the second shot
that he did get and again he got a nice
advantage something that gary said that
magnus has a certain modus operandi and
his modus operandi is not going for
those all-or-nothing attacks which do
come from that particular line of the
sveshnikov I would be chased into the
double King Park but maybe we'll see
this fashion a cough again
Maurice jump in what's your prediction
for game 12 double king pawns I don't
think he wants to see anymore novelties
dropped on those lines it's clear that
Fabi has stuff there's gold in them
there hills he came up with one with
Bishop d2 then he plays before he's
enlivening the play in such a way that
you're really asking for it to go back
into some sharp line with the black
pieces where a draw is enough for you to
go into a very advantageous tie break so
I see him going either double I see him
leaving the Sicilian that's that's what
I will say I think he has a third
defense waiting just in case in his
pocket so he may not be a 45 I think he
has a third defense waiting somewhere in
the wings which he might throw out it
might be the Shaka for the last game
sorry
so maybe that's something you take but I
think I think that I would but what I
will say is I think he's leaving this is
slow I think it's time to put that one
to rest cause it was just too dangerous
both of them could have really cost him
the match right all right and so it's
best that he ducks out of there and then
take his chances in the tiebreak where
he will be favored well if he could get
to the tiebreaker I think he would be
very very nice I mean yeah as we saw in
New York City again our congratulations
to Joe and June a phenomenal perform
it's just great great stuff by the
women's world champion as she defends
her title it's been championship today
in chess Jennifer we we witnessed two
great players going toe-to-toe tonight
man can get the edge yeah I think the
biggest chance for decisive p.m. is the
last one okay that's pretty easy to say
and if it's not we will be back on
Wednesday but first championship Monday
I have never been this excited to see a
chess game and I've been pretty excited
to see chess games before so join us
cancel your Monday extend that
Thanksgiving weekend one more day or
explain to your boss that you must work
to monitor maybe three or four the
coverage begins at 9:00 a.m. local here
in st. Louis which is actually the
Challenger Fabiano Carolina's home join
us for game 12 will it end on Monday
thank you for sharing your Thanksgiving
weekend with us
[Music]